a day to
help
kind of honor those people that we've
lost to overdose
kind of support those people that are
still dealing with substance use
disorders
breaking down the walls of substance
abuse that was the goal of a gathering
tonight as recovering addicts and
families who've lost loved ones to drugs
stood up to share their stories on
international overdose awareness day
sasha loftis was there sasha joining us
in studio with more on their message
brian and denise recovering addicts and
those who've lost loved ones hope events
like this encourage anyone struggling to
come forward this as we see overdose
numbers here in las vegas continue to
climb
recovery is a thesaurus it's not a
dictionary powerful words from those
who've seen the worst and started over i
lived in the flood channels for a little
bit
i seen friends of mine overdosed down
there recovering addicts turned
advocates stood up wednesday to share
their journeys while also honoring the
lives lost on international overdose
awareness day and as much as i encourage
the participation of the solution the
one thing that i know is i participated
in the problem this display of shoes
represents the
619 people who died of drug overdoses in
clark county last year nearly 60 percent
of those were opioid related it's about
meeting people where they're at and
helping them reduce harm associated with
substance use chris reynolds of southern
nevada health consortium says he hopes
gatherings like this help more people
come forward and ask for help and so
once we can break that stigma and be
able to talk to people about an issue as
if it's an everyday issue we'll make
leaps and bounds forward while those
who've been through it want their
stories to help others move forward and
choose sobriety this isn't a war on
drugs this is about saving our people
this is about you know adding value to
this experience
according to the southern nevada harm
reduction alliance drug overdose deaths
are up 48 percent from 2019 they call
fentanyl a significant problem as it
continues to drive a spike in opioid
related deaths brian up 48 percent